the i-team following the political
fallout of the assault on the capitol
leadership in both the house and senate
are pushing president trump's cabinet to
use their constitutional authority to
remove him from office
otherwise they say they will the
i-team's david charns is live in the
newsroom
with more on what this means david yeah
kirsten in breaking in just the past
couple of minutes we have heard from
president trump for the first time today
releasing a new video message on twitter
condemning the violence
and conceding to president-elect biden
take a listen
to those who engage in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay the president's twitter
account just
unblocked now both speaker nancy pelosi
and soon to be majority leader chuck
schumer called on vice president pence
and the cabinet to invoke the 25th
amendment i did speak with a
csn professor today about this now this
would be when
that the cabinet can push a sitting
president out of office
if they feel he or she can no longer
perform their duties
i spoke with dr francis carlton he
studies political science and he says
this is a real complicated process the
vice president would have to initiate
this
and then the majority of the cabinet
would have to sign on to it and then
there would have to be a two-thirds vote
in congress to then remove the president
given that he would already have left
office you could still vote on those
articles of impeachment
but the more important one would be that
separate language in the constitution
that says that you can vote on
qualification for future elected office
and on that the senate would only need a
majority
now three of our members of congress are
supporting impeachment proceedings which
would remove him from office though of
course just 13 days left of his term
but starting that impeachment process
now and actually then passing it
whenever they want to would mean
president
trump would never be able to hold
elected office
again